[Musique]
les heurts se sont ces prières qui
scandent les différents moments de la
journée donc ces petits vallons amicel
ou d'un petit livre qu'on a avec soin
pour prier mais se livre donc qui a une
fonction pratique est aussi un objet
d'orfèvrerie comme un bijou
[Musique]
ce livre est enfermé dans une reliure en
or émail et avec cet effet de réserve
qui permet de créer ce décor de
mauresque et de rinceaux d'arabesques
vous voyez des bandeaux aussi des
mailles blanc qui portent des
inscriptions qui sont des bouts de
prière est au centre de ces deux plats
de reliure on voit ces deux grandes
plaques de cornaline donc c'est une
pierre orange d'origine orientale
il ya des rubis qui alternent avec des
turquoises les pierres ne sont pas
fast et ne sont pas taillés mais sont
laissés brut et ça c'est tout à fait
inhabituel dans leurs favoris de la
renaissance
par contre c'est tout à fait courant
dans l'orfèvrerie ottomane
il est certain que on a voulu imiter le
décor des objets précieux ottoman
[Musique]
il a été acheté par le roi pour faire
une et rennes c'est à dire un cadeau à
sa nièce jeanne d'albret
enquin 138 elle a dix ans tout juste
tous ces objets extrêmement précieux
de la cour des valois ont déconné
pratiquement plus que par les
inventaires tout ça a vraiment disparu
dans les guerres de religion c'est tout
à fait miraculeux qu'un tel objet été
préservé henri iv l'a héritée de sa mère
jeanne d'albret l'a fait ramener à paris
marie médicis elle donc femme d'henri iv
la prélever de ces choses ramené de
navarre pour le mettre dans son cabinet
au louvre donc c'est assez drôle de
penser qu'au début du xviie siècle il
était déjà au louvre avant de commencer
une longue errance qui l'a conduit
jusqu'en angleterre où nous l'avons
rachetée
[Musique]